good morning it gets Tuesday it's
question Tuesday the day that I answer
real questions from real nerdfighters
let's get right to it why is Hamlet's
father also named Hamlet just some
old-fashioned Shakespearean doubling by
the way that'll be discussed in detail
in next week's crash course literature
do you think the two fields movie is
actually good or do you feel obliged to
say that because it's based off of your
book that's a good question to be
totally honest if I didn't like it I
would still try to find nice things to
say about it like oh the set design is
amazing or man that Ansel Elgort sure
looks good in a Rik Smits Jersey but in
fact I actually love the movie now I
might be wrong I am not at all objective
but yeah I love it
do you think people who read are more
empathetic than those who don't yeah
there are actually studies that show a
correlation between empathy and reading
at least when it comes to literary
fiction where do you stand on elbows I
don't I only stand on my feet I'm not
very coordinated
I don't watch your videos why should I
look I don't want to criticize anyone
but that is a terrible question Tuesday
question because if I answer it you
definitionally won't hear my
justification for why you should watch
my videos because you don't watch my
videos but just brings up a bigger
question how do you get to the people
that aren't inside the camera maybe
there's no one inside the camera maybe
I'm just staring into the void oh god I
feel an existential crisis coming on
thoughts on the ocean I don't know the
tide goes in the tide goes out what does
it even really matter anymore
are there more stars in the universe or
grains of sand on earth we'll see that's
an interesting and beautiful question
that makes me grateful to be able to
apprehend the universe suddenly I've
been lifted out of my funk
I think there are more stars more stars
than there are grains of sand on earth
there are a lot of grains of sand any
way you can find more info in the
doobly-doo how are you enjoying
participating in the art assignment oh
it's so fun it's the most fun I've had
in a long time it actually reminds me of
the early days of vlogbrothers because
there's this tight-knit community like
doing projects together and responding
to each other's work it's just really
really awesome how excited are you for
the divergent movie in two weeks
I am already bought my tickets for
opening day excited what are your
predictions for this year's IndyCar
season how did you guys find out that
I'm a secret fan of IndyCar anyway I
think the Indy 500 is gonna be one for a
second time by Tony Kanaan and I think
the series title is gonna go to
willpower and yes that is his real name
can you say dftba in french I can try
dftba
why do writers use symbolism okay let's
say that you have a headache and you
want to tell someone about it and you
say I have a headache and other people
are like yeah whatever everybody gets
headaches so your headache is not a
regular headache it's a serious
headaches so you say my brain is on fire
to try to help these people understand
that this is a headache that needs
attention that's a metaphor right and
you use it so that you can be understood
now let's say you want to take those
same images tech principles but apply
them to a much more complex idea than
having a headache like for instance the
yearning that one feels for one's dreams
and you can see the dream but you can't
cross the bay to get to the green light
that embodies your dream and you want to
talk about how socioeconomic class in
America is a barrier a Bey like barrier
some would say that stands between you
and the green light and makes that gap
unbridgeable now you can't just talk
about that stuff directly but when you
talk about it symbolically it becomes
more powerful because instead of being
abstract it becomes kind of observable
so I think that's why all right what's
the next question who has the best but
you or Hank I don't think either of us
has the best but the best but I've ever
personally seen is actually Wil
Wheaton's wait did I just think that or
did I say it out loud have you ever
dreamed to be a pizza no that's one of
those drinks that seems initially
promising but in fact I think it would
be a horrible nightmare like just
imagine smelling like pizza and knowing
that you would taste like pizza but then
also knowing that if you eat yourself
you will die and ergo not be able to
ever eat pizza again what are you most
excited about right now what a great
question that's something I should ask
myself every day I think right now it's
the art assignment but I want to know
what you're most excited about so let me
know in comments Hank I'll see you on
Friday